hello ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls this is lei yung now I'm in
butterfiy so glad to see you guys hi
[Applause]
first time you played an instrument yeah
when I was six years old that at that
time is my first to play the piano but I
don't like him my mom told me hey you
should you have to do it you have to do
it oh no I don't like it but when I was
14 years old I saw
usek is very important for my life first
nickname
shree shree shrah means handsome
handsome my mom gives me the name first
CD you ever bought maybe is Michael
Jackson Billie Jean the very big one
first pad yeah I have a cat when I was
70 years old
like on 2008 I when I went to Korean to
be a trainee so I gave the cat to
another friends sorry I just called a
cat oh my gosh don't have a name yeah
for sure
I just called the cat hi cat yeah in
Chinese hey mom
oh I'm so sorry about this oh my gosh
the first song you composed a composer
once I talked about just talked about
weather and yeah it's not a dope song
okay next question first thing you do
when you wake up go too late first
impression of America it's a very big
country and everybody looks good
everybody looks different
yeah I really like a New York hotdog I'm
always search about a New York Hakata I
want a hotdog
first show you ever bench every day
compose music and make music so I don't
have time to watch the whole thing okay
first performance Wow
when that was 30 years old I'd perform
in Hunan China shop this is my hometown
doing the competition top three of the
TV show yeah I'm very good first time
you knew you you love love the dancing
you know uh it's hard to say because I
just want to use the dance be my weapon
to get a lot of recognization so when my
performance not it's not bad yeah okay
hope you like it
I buy the house to my mom yeah it's very
big my mom when I was young my mom give
me a lot of money right so when I get a
lot of money I buy the big house to my
mom yeah mom you're right yeah good job
mom
first apartment I always live in hotel
so I don't have a parliament I should
have got one I should buy one yeah
first meal you ever cook I make a toast
very well you know
toast is very delicious you know I think
I have a talented about how to make a
toast so host yeah it has been a lot of
fun thank you guys yeah bye
[Music]